this is Meg Amy Beth and Joe my girls
her way of getting into mischief you
guys to be here in this house this movie
what a dream come true does it bring
back memories of filming last year and
just being a part of this I was just
thinking about we spent Halloween and
Sleepy Hollow cemetery that's truly
where Laurie texted me said you want to
go visit yeah on Halloween night yeah
that was so wild and just this town is
incredible it is it's such a great story
what do you think it is about little
women that it's transcended time maybe I
think Greta could speak the best about
that and all the signature laura has
something wiser than what I'm about to
say but and with all the respect and
admiration for the actual work because
none of us would be here without it
and and with all the the awareness
fountain it is this is Greta its movie
you know and I think the reason we're
sitting here is in large part in huge
part because always a male cop but
really cos Greta and that's why I would
hope and I implore people to see this
thing and not as a selling point or
whatever but as a back that for those
that have seen the other versions too
this is a new this is a new thing about
this how all the other movies that have
been made you know that movie came in
the 30s you know that movie came in the
night this is a 20-19 it is so much
you're wearing the capes and the you
know but god it's modern it's so
fabulous it's like a rock not a rom-com
but like it feels like that in a way
like it's very poppy well it's also I
think the first time because of Greta's
genius and how she navigated this
adaptation it is Louis's story and the
story of Little Women yeah somehow woven
together beautifully but also and I love
listening to Timmy talk about it even
when we were on set - it's a movie she's
given all of us about what it is to find
yourself your characters trying to
figure out who he is and what love means
to him the same way we all are and what
it means to be an artist the sacrifice
of art and also I think it's the most
modern the
experience of telling the story of
ambition with comfort with ease that
ambition is a gorgeous thing to have
when you want to be an artist or a
servant of the world you know it's very
interesting because I'm sorry because I
want to jump on that because that is
like so important the Lord just said and
I want to be able to just say things
that are soundbite e and can be fit in a
sentence too but that is like so huge
because the misinterpretation of this
movie or the flippant way to look at it
would be to think that it doesn't the
stakes aren't high or something and my
experience as a human through Laurie but
just being on set with someone like
Lorde during or Meryl Streep or to see
Greta work on a bigger thing I supposed
to Lady Bird here and what I wish but it
was like it when you're young people are
mirrors to you your identities confirmed
to you by other people and even if
you're you know even if you're in your
20s whatever young actor it's still the
case and I felt the experience of
growing within Greta's like a worldview
within her her her universe and same
goes for Laura the howling story zaps
and I got so much out of this movie
which has not been put the question was
I apologize for personalizing it but uh
but and even just be in this house right
now this is and that's the irony that it
is Sony distributing it or that it has
been that it's a big thing as some
saying it's become the instrument
because and it is so independently
minded she was so fiercely independent
in her voice so it felt like in an indie
movie in that way too and so I had read
Timothy that you had found a watch Dark
Knight and that had inspired you to
become an actor and then the fact now
this is 360 you're playing a role that
Christian Bale has played oh yes yes
like this is crazy
no like 360 for you no no absolutely
yeah I mean um I I that feels a little
self I can't throw myself in the same
thing but but you know it's a great role
I think Retta I think he did you know
his was already excellently an Armstrong
is already excellent
I think reddit did was I gotta be
careful when I think this is Little
Women whatever but she gave him real
agency real groundedness vulnerability
and it's also an ideal he's a bit of an
ideal of a young man but uh tonight was
about the proposal see that's what I
love about the impetuousness of it
sometimes because that's what it is to
be young it went in with a privilege you
know in that but uh but you know a lot
of the questions about Laurie in the
relationship that he has with these
sisters can be gender because it's
obvious and yet like it's it goes so you
know it's not a tit-for-tat you know
thing yeah and I was gonna say when I
watched the movie I walked out of
theater and I always like to take my
notes right after so I can like really
get my thoughts straight and I said you
know I know that much has been made
about you being the Internet's boyfriend
like I've was in love with you if you
love Timothy Salome you will love him so
much
because this is also part of the the
genius of Greta Gerwig is you will also
love him not only because he's a
brilliant incredible actor in human
being but as Chris Cooper just said what
a gorgeous movie about men she's made a
film about kind men about generous men
and we need those movies desperately
this is for all of us as higher
discussing self and the character you've
played is it's also there's deep
fluidity in these relationships as as
childhood allows if given the proper you
know room to play and explore but it's
just so beautiful to find the generosity
of spirit and as these people are
growing up together hey can I add on one
more thing that I'm sorry it's just that
I know but it's so I feel what Laura's
so on it's what I took away from the
movies seeing it that I didn't expect
when I saw it alone and not to gender it
again but it was it was so fascinating
that Chris Cooper that's maybe the most
heartbreaking scene to me is Chris
Cooper outside and Joe going up to the
same weren't you going inside and
because the reason I was spoiling but
the this is what sorry no but that the
men like it's shot you know there is no
I don't know what the opposite of the
lecherous male gaze it's you know I'm
saying but that's not what this is it's
not a vengeful thing it's it's it's but
also it doesn't like lugar ELLs a
beautiful man
and is shot to be that you know like but
it doesn't see any way so I I love that
Laura made that point because it's not
it's not the movies necessarily about
it's not what's at the forefront of the
movie and yet it's it's treated with
life delving it with with truth you know
I know you bring such dedication to your
love of Joe and so we live your kind of
with us we get to fall in love with her
through you and you love her for her
complicated nature for her aged for her
poetry yeah as opposed to the guy in the
movie goes whoa that's a lot just
beautiful right this is a great point
Saoirse was in here talking about it
before what is it that like in every
movie she's gonna scream in your face
well it seems to be my face yeah it's
like is this a new thing like Lady Bird
there's like you know before she's like
your face in this movie there's also
like this meme going around the internet
of like Saoirse yelling at Timothy is
like my mood forever yes she does that
but she you made everyone fall in love
with you so much she that she mean it
just left me a bunch of no I don't you
know well you know what she's they're so
bad for the way you treated her Lee and
lady very exactly that was a character
[Laughter]
but the amazing thing the sir for truly
and you know our relationship in a
vacuum her as a human in a vacuum
nothing to me is that her I don't want
to say her heart because that sounds
cheesy like her essence what is out of
control in some way to maybe thinks to
her parents I don't know but it's so in
the right place and she's not lying I do
feel like she's you know yes yes you
should make sure yeah yeah I felt good
the last thing I want to ask you is
about these matching sweaters at the
Gotham awards I mean so she got a ship
giving this award and Greta and Noah
voice I noticed and Lauren Dern
sweatshirts did this amazing collection
of an homage to David Lynch and so they
were both sweaters with actually my you
know that was gonna happen or not know
they surprised me and of course my son
was freaking out because even better
nose like Ellery what do you think of my
sweater he's like you're also wearing my
Nana because my mother who was in wild
at heart is on the oh my other other
sleeve so it was it was a family affair
amazing and as you walked in Timothy was
congratulating you on this it's new
honor what do you guys make of this I
mean it's just the sort of award season
and at every turn I'm hearing little
women in these performances I couldn't
even pick up favorite performance from
this ensemble when you make of all the
buzz can I say something about it do it
man I'm sitting next to such an
incredible actress and an incredible
human it's someone that I could say
because I work with her so it's not you
know
this is an incredible person so talk
about one but two roles that are
exemplifying that this year are not even
her personhood her in touching this with
the human condition let's say it's
awesome and and has amazing kids and and
you're a great person
so no no it's true it's an incredible
person and I'm so lucky to know him and
I determined to work with him forever I
was gonna savour it when I was doing my
research for these interviews and I
promise I'll um my through my research
with the interviews what we're so
fabulous and made me so proud for you is
that in every many of the articles they
were like oh with you know legends like
Meryl Streep and large area and in so
many of the things and then the rest of
the cast cuz it's a lot of you know up
and comers and and so like how cool is
that that you're in the like what a
career to be like oh yeah you know those
legends the other ones Meryl Streep you
know it's so ridiculous and I think we
all were just standing around and every
time actually anything Meryl said that's
true it's like I remember with searched
you were standing there like do you want
something anything was so special so we
all you know continued the joy but and
they were on the group chat and
Merrill's like lol yeah it's so special
[Music]